vous nous avez demandé est ce que le
gouvernement pourrait décider de fermer
les épiceries bien la réponse est non
puisque le gouvernement du québec
considère d épicerie comme un service
primordial le mapaq quant à lui va
s'occuper de la sécurité alimentaire et
de la disponibilité ce qui nous amène à
la deuxième question
aurons-nous une pénurie d'aliments il
est vrai que les tablettes ont été vidés
par beaucoup de consommateurs inquiets
mais d'ici quelques jours la plupart de
celles ci seront remplis à nouveau selon
les distributeurs que nous avons
consultés ainsi que le conseil canadien
du commerce de détail qui représente les
différentes bannières
l'approvisionnement reste inchangé
d'autant plus que la frontière avec les
états unis restent ouvertes pour le
commerce des marchandises qui ne
proviennent pas du canada dont le
conseil par contre de ne pas aller trop
souvent à l'épicerie mais c'est plus une
question de se protéger de protéger les
autres qu'une question
d'approvisionnement